nous sommes un opérateur français d'éco
mobilité partagée
nous avons développé une plateforme qui
permet de gérer et plusieurs services de
mobilité à savoir de l'auto partage de
véhicules électriques du covoiturage de
la gestion de points de charge et de
l'information voyageurs
donc notre offre de service s'adresse à
trois communautés les collectivités les
entreprises
et puis l'habitat social le service de
vélos à assistance électrique est l'une
des briques de notre plate forme d'éco
mobilité que nous essayons de déployer
sur le plateau de saclay il vient en
complément des infrastructures de
transport existantes et l'objectif c'est
vraiment de faciliter la liaison entre
la vallée et le plateau de saclay le
service qui s'adresse autant aux aux
habitants de la ville dort c'est qu'aux
étudiants et salariés qui arrive sur les
deux gars et qui font quotidiennement le
trajet val et plateau de saclay le
service est une expérimentation de
quatre mois elle s'inscrit dans le cadre
d'un projet européen
on mettra en place 20 vélos à assistance
électrique à titre expérimental sur
cette station autour de la commune
d'orsay l'expérimentation de vélos à
assistance électrique autour de la ville
dort c'est s'inscrit dans un projet plus
global qui va permettre de mettre en
place une flotte plus importante avec 70
vélo électrique sur un territoire plus
important de la communauté paris saclay
mais aussi un service d'auto partage de
voitures électriques de réservation de
points de charge et aussi de covoiturage
l'ensemble étant gérée sur une même
plate forme d'éco mobilité pour les
autres qui sont intéressés par le
service
ils s'inscrivent sur le site internet
clair point mobile ou depuis
l'application client mobile
ils valident leur badge sur la borne qui
installé actuellement à la mairie
d'orchies l'utilisateur arrive au niveau
du vélo avec son badge
il va ce sera la boîte à clé et là il ya
le guichet de la boîte qui va se
déverrouiller et on peut récupérer les
clés il ya une clé pour le vélo et 1
la clé pour le canada